Quies coucou je m'appelle
noir PL
g je vais tout faire pour'aer à
surmonter peur mme si je dois en mourir
et pour ta gouverne je suis immortel
donc ça prendra tout le temps qu'il
faudra
[Musique]
Orion j'ai l'immense bonheur de te
présenter les C autre entité
[Musique]
nocturne quiétude
sommeil insom je suis bon pour me faire
virer broule de
bruit naturellement
dou venir
br compte que tout pourrait partir en
cacahuète imagine qu'il fait je te et te
ralentissse et que tu sais qui finisse
par te rattraper et te fasse disparaître
à tout jamais et que le concept de
l'obscurité cesse d'exister et que
l'Univers tel qu'on le connaît soit
modifié de faon
permanenteable ça pourrait véritablement
arriver
c'est peu
[Musique]
probable